hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played yesterday in
the Croatian chess League it is myself
versus a national candidate Master
Marian okra and it's uh quite a wild
game you guys uh will will really enjoy
this one because we've made some
mistakes we we made some good moves and
in the end is just a very very cool game
uh so going into this game I already
faced Mario once it was three years ago
I even showed the game on the channel I
I was able to win in a nice miniature uh
some 17 moves or something if you
haven't seen it will be the first link
in the description below and I was
thinking okay probably he will he will
want revenge so I have to be very
careful and also this is my third game
in the creation league and uh yeah the
first two games ended I I I got two
draws so I I also I I mean I I have the
white pieces I also want to play this
one for a win so I I didn't really know
what he was gonna play but I was I was
ready to play some chess uh so I opened
with Ponte E4 as I usually do and he
replied with Ponte the D5 he went for
the Scandinavian defense which is okay
for for me because I played the
Scandinavian myself so I know what to
expect I play the captures on the five
Queen captures and Knight the C3 now I I
prefer the queen to D6 line he went for
Queen to A5 this is the uh still the
main line of the Scandinavian defense
and I played the D4 these are pretty
standard moves you want to play against
uh this line uh this line you want to
play D4 Knight C3 Knight to F3 and then
pretty much all depends on what what he
does so Knight to F6 we have Knight to
F3 and now Bishop to F5 much better than
Bishop to G4 Bishop to G4 you can
challenge the bishop right away and then
if he goes back you can even play G4
let's see bishop g595 and you have a a
great position with white you're gonna
put this bishop on F4 you're gonna put
this bishop on G2 and you will have a a
spectacular position so Bishop to F5 is
preferred here uh I played Knight to E5
I'm wasting some Tempe with the Knight
but uh this is um the way to play this
you you always have this nasty pressure
on the queen with with Knight to the C4
and this is just a beautiful piece on E5
so he played E6 here uh you you should
play C6 here but okay uh E6 is also
playable I guess uh but then you have to
uh face this Knight to the C form which
I played I played Knight to C4 he played
Queen to B4 I played Pawn to A3 okay he
could play Queen day six instead of B4
but that's just going under the mask of
the bishop uh not really Pleasant so I
played A3 and I pushed this queen all
the back all the way back to E7 now this
is a position I've never seen before
it's a very weird one the queen blocking
the bishop like this so I felt like I
should be better here yeah but still
it's very unclear on how to how to
actually continue I played Bishop to F4
uh continuing development he played
Knight to C6 uh you don't really have to
worry about Knight to B5 or anything
since he can just always castle and now
I uh went into sort of a deep think here
because uh
uh he he always has this nasty pressure
of just castling and pushing E5 but also
after he just castles uh the rook and
the Knight will be attacking my D4 pawn
and there's no good way to actually
defend my D4 pawn and for some reason
whenever I play White against the
Scandinavian I always end up giving up
this uh this D4 pawn and it's also what
I did in the game how uh however you
should continue this with Knight to E5
and the subtle matters once and for all
and now black will not have pressure on
the D4 Pawn uh you either capture or or
you can Castle Queen side here but if
you Castle Queen side now the Knight
captures on C6 uh messes up his Pawn
structure completely so he would have to
trade I'm gonna take he's gonna play
Rook to d8 I'm gonna play Queen to F3
and now okay it's it's a game let's say
Knight to D5 we trade captures captures
White Castles Queen side and everything
is perfectly fine but I played Bishop to
D3 here and it's a straight up Pawn
sacrifice uh just giving up the D4 Ponte
speed uh to fasten my development which
is not a great move so he played Knight
captures on D4 he said thank you for the
pawn I castle kingside and he castled
Queen side and I just continued with
Rook to E1 and now he played Knight
captures on C2 uh he's giving up a night
temporarily but he's gonna win back the
bishop on D3 and it's not the the best
of moves because I can always play this
Knight to D6 check which I did not find
if Knight's the D6 check uh then uh if
capture with the pawn then The Rook is
no longer attacking the bishop here so
he would have to play Rook captures I
would play Bishop captures Queen
captures and now Bishop captures on C2
this is the uh the way to play it he
would be
um up upon but I would be up the
exchange so definitely the way to go
however I I was I was actually happy
that he removed my C2 Pawn because I was
constantly looking for ways to bring my
queen over to the queen side to actually
attack the black king because now I have
the open C file I have the knights I
have the bishop attacking C7 I have the
uh the possibility of Queen entering the
game and I play Queen captures on C2 and
he played Bishop captress on D3 of
course that's that was the whole point
of Knight captures on C2 and I played
Queen to A4 now putting pressure on his
A7 pawn and here he went into a deep
think and he went for the uh for the
well it seems like for for the wrong
idea he played Queen to C5 he defended
his A7 Pawn the way to play this is the
capture on C4 first and now the problem
is okay if Queen captures obviously
nothing happens you play Queen to C5
next the problem is what happens if
Queen captures an A7 probably what he
was worried about uh because then let's
say queen to C5 I can play Queen a
checking the seven Queen captures on B7
and you know it it doesn't feel
spectacular having your king and D7 but
after Knight D5 you should be fine Rook
8 to D1 and okay it's it's a bad Square
for the for the king but you can you can
definitely play this uh and and black
will be much better however he went for
Queen to C5 first he didn't wanna
uh go into this and now I I found this
beautiful Knight the E5 movement first
uh it's a funny moment because uh it's
classical you have time to think I
almost went for the night and then uh I
stopped because I saw if 95 then worked
the D4 and I was very happy that I saw
this you know instead of blundering the
game but then I started to look at 95
even more and then I thought maybe it's
a great move and it is it is in fact the
only move that gives white the advantage
is the strongest move recommended by the
engine and I played Knight to E5 now
saying that the Rook the D4 is in fact
impossible because if he goes for Rook
to D4 attacks my queen and the bishop I
just play Bishop to E3 and that's it
Rook captures and A4 I'm gonna play
Bishop captures on C5 and now his Rook
is hanging his Bishop is hanging okay my
bishop and C5 is hanging as well but
it's not as important he he will have to
move the Rook I'm just gonna trade once
and then capture the bishop on D3 and
I'm up a full piece so that's the one
something you can do the other thing if
you
uh instead of this Rook the deform will
play Queen to D4 which is also possible
now I just play Knight captures on F7
which was my idea all along just
eliminating the F7 Pawn attacking the
two Rooks he will trade I will capture
Rook the D4 now attacks the bishop and
the Knight here and I'm gonna play but
let's say Bishop B5 Rook captures and
Knight captures on h8 uh and I'm gonna
be up material so that was my plan uh he
however went Bishop back to G6 uh
getting the bishop out of harms away and
also defending his F7 pawn and now I
played Pawn to B4 and I was very happy
when I played this because I I I thought
okay now now my position is just clearly
winning uh he he cannot take on C3 If he
if he captures my knight I'm just gonna
play Queen captures on A7 the Knight
covers D7 I'm gonna Checkmate him or
even if he defends that the only way to
defend this I found Knight to the D7 but
it cracks or immediately rotate the C1
and once the queen moves uh any move
wins here literally any move Knights the
C6 is the quickest way to win and
there's just no defense you cannot
capture because of Queen captures on C7
Checkmate and if E5 blocking the bishop
you can just play Queen 8 check and
after the Knight blocks you can just
play Queen captures and after this queen
captures on the 80 check King to E6 and
now a very nice Rook captures an E5
Checkmate uh so you cannot capture the
Knight he went Queen back to B6 it's the
only move to basically continue the game
and I played Knight to B5 again the best
way to continue uh the thing is uh I I
had to calculate what if A6 what if C6
would have King to B8 so those are all
valid moves for black because obviously
the A7 Pawn is hanging uh but none of it
uh works for him the problem is if if
for example A6 you can just play Knight
captures on C7 and there's just uh no
way to hold this there's too much
pressure like King to B8 if you try to
run away there's always this nasty
Knights to see for idea which is uh in
fact an idea in most of the lines
um in some lines you can even trap the
black the black queen if Queen to D4
just Knight captures an H on A6 and a
nice double check if King to C8 now you
can even play Knight the B6 check you
give up a piece rotate the C1 with check
and no more moves for the black king you
will have to give up the queen so he
played Knights the D5 instead which is
uh which is definitely better you have
to give up your uh your your A7 pawn and
now I have to decide do I want to
capture it or do I want to improve my
position with Knight to C4 first uh I I
thought maybe okay maybe it's better to
capture if Knights of the C4 maybe he
has Queen to A6 and then after Knight
captures an A7 it's a it's a fun line
but uh let's say King to B8 and now I'm
gonna have to trade there's uh no better
move and once I trade let's say Knight
to C6 check I will pick up the Rook King
to C8 Knight captures and King captures
but I thought I could do even better
than this so instead after this Knight
to D5 move I played Knight captures on
A7 right away and after King to B8 at
night 8 to C6 with check he played B
captures if you go here then this is
just Checkmate uh so he had the capture
I played Knight captures with check and
he played King to C8 and here we have a
very very complicated position uh where
I am winning but I have to be very very
precise about it so feel free to pause
the video and try to find this uh very
elusive idea while I give you a couple
of seconds
foreign
this uh well I it took me quite some
time to find it over the board and for
so you just want to enjoy the show it is
Bishop to G5 this is the strongest move
and I will explain why but uh just in
case you're wondering why Queen to A8 uh
check isn't better it's playable of
course but after King the D7 Queen
capture 78 King captures on C6 now you
can throw in let's say a rotate the C1
with check he's gonna hide the King on
B7 and now okay my Bishop is hanging I
have to move the bishop back and this is
the position he will he he has uh
problems developing his King side and it
will be very very hard to play for him
probably he has to play Bishop captures
on B4 uh give up The Rook here trade
here on E1 and try to try to survive
this game which is fine for white uh
Bishop to G5 the move I played is even
stronger and you'll see why the problem
is uh he can't what can he play now uh
now he no longer has this Knight
captures an effort and at the end of the
line and if you try something like
Bishop to D6 now the Rooks are defending
each other it doesn't really matter just
Knight captures on the eight and now it
doesn't really matter you you can play
F6 you can play H6 you can play Knight
to C3 to attack the queen I can always
wiggle out Queen to A8 with check King
to D7 and now Queen to F3 getting the
queen out of Harm's Way and also
attacking the Knight on C3 and if he
goes back Knight D5 I just play Knight
captures and F7 Andy frook f8 and now
kinda attacking me just Knights the E5
with check and now you cannot capture
because of Queen captures on f8 so he he
would have to move the king I will move
the queen and again white is just much
much better the problem is he played
Bishop to E7 and it's a very strong
defensive resource uh he just gives back
material and I have nothing better than
to take it so I played Bishop characters
on E7 he played Knight captures and I
play Knight captures on E7 with check he
played King to B7 here and here I felt
like I did everything properly I I
really uh played I played a a fine
series of moves and I should have
something here but I had like two two
minutes on the clock and uh I saw the
threat of Rook the D2 Rook the D2 and he
was gonna have pressure on my F2 Pawn
then I'm probably gonna have to play
some like Rook F1 he's gonna bring his
other Rook into the game for free and
all my advantages will uh evaporate and
uh you know uh looking for for his
threats I failed to find threads of my
own uh and I could have ended the game
in the next move but I I missed it but
luckily you guys are here so feel free
to pause the video once again and try to
find the uh absolutely crushing move for
white while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing that the
King has really no nowhere to go and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is a rook the E5 and Rook the E5
completely removes the threat of Rook to
D2 so congratulations to everyone who
found it now when I ask you like this
probably all of you found it in an
instant but I was unable to find it over
the board I have no idea why later I
checked it on my phone and I was like
wow I mean
how do you miss this like it's uh uh
it's uh the the only way to play and
it's so so so natural to to go for a
rook lift I have no idea how I missed
this and I was very sad about it and I
was so sad that I thought uh maybe maybe
you know I shouldn't even show this game
but I thought yeah maybe you know
sharing it will uh you know alleviate
the pain uh so that that's why I'm
showing you uh how I blundered it so
here he uh if he played C6 doesn't
really matter there's no defense against
Rook to B5 he plays something like C6
you can even play Knife captures on C6
doesn't matter The Rook is just too
strong Rook B5 checking C7 remember we
also have the other Rook so let's take
into D6 Rook to D1 check and you have no
more moves you have to start giving up
material with them like Bishop D3 Queen
D5 and so on however I missed that I
played Rook a to D1 I just uh was
looking for ways to stop Rook to D2 and
now I imagine he was very happy with
this he played Bishop to H5 he he's
forcing me to take so that he can get
his Rook into the game and I captured
again Rook to D7 was better here but I
was um in too much time trouble Rook
capture 78 Rook captures and now I
played B5 now my idea was if Rook to D2
I can always play Queen E4 check
centralize my queen and then defend
against any and all threats but he
played Rook to D4 which is much much
better now he's not allowing any checks
I played Queen to C2 and he played Queen
to D6 and now there's no way for me to
avoid the queen trade he's just gonna
play Rook to D1 and that's it and I was
I was all I was sad before but now I was
very sad I played Knight to C6 as also
my knight is hanging and he just played
Rook to D1 and he solves everything Rook
captures Queen captures uh sorry Queen
captures Queen captures Bishop captures
and now I have the same game Knight
against the bishop and I know I'm worse
here because the pawns are weak here he
has a bishop on my knight and the the
game is being played on both sides of
the board so of course the bishop is
better and uh uh but okay it's a team
event and I I I want to do my best not
to lose the game so okay maybe I can
hold this I played Knight to the d8 with
Chuck uh he played King to B6 and I
played Knight captures on F7 he played
King captures on B5 and now the question
is how to continue how how do you stop
the past C Pawn probably best is to to
start bringing the king into the game I
went for Knights to G5 I thought that I
have to take at least one more pawn and
then uh maybe maybe then bring the king
into the game it was better to play King
to F1 right away but okay he played
Bishop to B3 this is the strongest move
a defense on E6 I play Knight captures
on H7 and I didn't have time to
calculate I knew that I wanted to
capture the pawn now either I can stop
the C Pawn or I can't stop the C pawn
and he played King to C4 which was uh I
was a very happy when I saw King to C4 I
just didn't want to see C5 on the board
and C5 is the best move for him the
point is that after C5 my knight after
uh the Knight comes back into the game
he needs to play Bishop to D5 cut off my
knight and now the C Pawn is just
winning I can play Knights to F7 try to
get a bit it's uh the king is too slow
if I try King to F1 you can just play
King to A4 and I feel like King day one
king D2 doesn't really matter he's gonna
capture on A3 and now of course the king
and Bishop will be able to escort the
pawn so I would have to go the other way
around Knight F7 now he's gonna play C4
and now there's nothing better I have to
play Knight to D6 tracking day four and
uh if I allow the pawn I'm losing I have
to give up the Knight and this will be
uh winning for him unless uh there's
some miracle save here but I I don't
think there is this should be winning
for black uh so instead of the C5 move
he played team to C4 and now I was very
very happy now I play Knight to G5 he
played King to C3 I played A4 saying
okay you capture I'm gonna capture on E6
he played C5 now he starts pushing A5
with Bishop to D5 and now Pawn to A6 I
said okay he's guarding AA but at least
I'm gonna push my Pawn all the way to A7
and the bishop will not be able to leave
this diagonal so at least some counter
play C4 I played A7 and now I'm even
threatening to pick up this Pawn because
if Bishop captures are just Queen he
played E5 and I played King to F1
uh probably what I should have done a
long a long time ago King to B2 now he
wants to start pushing the pawn I play
Knight to F3 and here I had like 30
seconds on the clock I thought I was
lost and then I then I found at Knight
to F3 and it holds now of course you
cannot capture if you capture then just
uh uh we're gonna bring a Queen into the
game black even gets a pawn to C2 but
it's still very much winning for white
you just start checking the black king
and that's it but he played C3 and I
played Knight captures on E5 that's the
point the king is on V2 and uh once the
the queen hits C1 I'm gonna play Knight
to D3 check and win his Queen back so he
played C2 I played King E2 I don't want
C1 to come with check and now he can't
play this if he plays uh C1 Queen I play
Knight the D3 check King to B1 I'm gonna
trade captures captures I started
pushing my pawns I created the second
weakness and then either my H Pawn or my
a pawn will be winning so instead after
King E2 he played King to C3 now he is
threatening C1 Queen because there are
no checks and I have to play Knight to
D3 I have to willingly go under the mask
of the bishop he played Bishop to C4 and
now I played a a queen uh he played
Bishop captures on D3 and this is the
way to do it if you play the uh C1 Queen
to try and keep more material on the
board you get the checkmate at Queen A5
check and I'll look at this King the uh
the four Queen to E5 is Checkmate or if
you go King to B3 doesn't matter Queen
to B4 with checking A2 Queen to D2 with
check you force a queen trade and you
are uh winning now of course so instead
after a queen he trades on D3 I have to
play King to F3 only move as I don't
want C1 to come with check and now he
played C1 Queen so now it's my three
pawns uh and the queen against his Queen
Bishop and the pawn and okay uh my team
was losing so I of course wanted to
somehow win but I knew that there was no
realistic way of winning this unless he
blunders terribly uh so I played Queen
to C6 check my only option is the trade
queens and then maybe I can push those
Pawns if his King will be a lot less
less active than my king but he made
sure that doesn't happen he played
Bishop C4 I started pushing H4 Queen to
D2 if he wants the uh maybe somehow move
the king and play Bishop D5 check to to
win my queen I played King to G3 and
then now Queen to D4 he centralizes his
queen and I want to do the same Queen F3
check Bishop to D3 and queen to F4 I
offer a queen trade and um uh he could
trade if he trades then my king is
already an F4 so he played King to C4
sort of to improve the activity of his
King before trading I played King G4 and
now okay captures captures and King to
D5 and this is not much much different
than if his King was on A1 or on B1 or
on B2 because his King is active enough
to stop my pawns King to G5 King to E6 I
played a pawn to G4 uh King to F7 was
played Ponte F4 uh Bishop to E4 and now
Ponte F5 with Bishop to D3 and now King
to F4 no way to actually push this G4 G5
he played G6 and he was in this position
and move 59 that we agreed to a draw as
there is nothing more to be done here if
I push the pawn then I'm never moving
his King from from the square and if I
trade uh not much different there's no
actual way to advance those pawns so
it's a it was a really fun game I love
playing against the Scandinavian
defenses especially in classical always
uh fun positions uh arise and uh yeah I
mean I was so so sad when I I was so
happy when I found Bishop to G5 it was
not an easy move to find I really you
know my brain heard calculating this out
uh but then here when I missed Rook to
D5 I was so incredibly sad so basically
a huge Miss for me Rook the E5 and a
huge Miss for him uh here after Knight
captures on H7 just advancing the C Pawn
right away yeah he probably thought that
my knight will be able to stop it but
after an ig5 Bishop D5 controls the
Knight and that's uh that's pretty much
it but okay we were both low on time so
mistakes were were bound to happen
that's right all in all a very nice game
could have gone uh either way and um in
the end I am happy with the result I'm
not happy with the not finding uh that
that rookie 5 move I'm very I mean I
keep repeating it but I'm still very sad
about that uh but yeah all in all uh you
know saving the game with some you know
nice night moves as you know Knights are
tricky bastards uh I I was you know in
the end happy with the overall result uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it like I said if you haven't
seen our game three years ago do check
it out first link in the description
below quite a nice one uh where I had
the black pieces a very nice miniature I
would like to thank Richard karp Laurie
and Andre gianicini rushing reptiles
YouTube Kathleen Northrop and Union for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day